[Music]
can you imagine
experiencing the zoo without actually
being in the zoo
[Music]
i think the people that i work with will
think that i'm mad sometimes a bit crazy
some people will say that i'm the
troublemaker so i am going around the
organization pretty much
uncovering opportunities and
possibilities and to unlock
innovation for the organization
one of the traditional problems is most
singaporeans they come to a zoo once
a year tourists will come once in a
lifetime
very very avid animal lovers amongst the
locals would be
a couple of times a year and they spent
a buck of their time actually
at home or outside of our parks pretty
much
how do i then reach out to these people
in their everyday lives
how do we make our brand relevant in
their everyday lives
there is a lot of creativity out there
it's how do you channel it to solve the
right problem in the first place
[Music]
so in munday we've identified five user
behaviors
in order to drive innovation so the
first user behavior is actually to be
user focused followed by being data
driven
being experimental to be really agile
and to continuously optimize
through techniques like journey mapping
as well as other tools to be able to
truly and deeply
empathize and know what our users
challenges and problem statements are
so there's a famous quote by albert
einstein if you had
60 minutes an hour to solve the problem
you should spend 55 minutes
defining the problem and only 5 minutes
brainstorming
we have been very very mindful to ensure
that we craft the problem
properly before we head into the next
phase which is ideation
the next stage would be prototyping
real-life feedback from users
and to learn from that feedback there
will be
different receptiveness of change
so one of the biggest challenges in the
organization is to have a common
language in order to be able to further
champion
consumer-centered design or
human-centered design
[Music]
my first task was really to find
like-minded colleagues within the
organization
and we were very fortunate to be able to
partner our life sciences team
so they were a great advocate of
leveraging digital
in the work that they do whether it's in
terms of engaging customers and
our guests or in terms of leveraging
technology
in their work so i think with design
thinking it's given us a fantastic
framework
it gives us a common language and a
common goal to all work towards
are you all ready for the show all right
children come to the zoo and they say
i'm just going there to see animals
okay they come they go and then that's
it
one of the key things that we observed
was um that's the power of
being in the same exhibit as an animal
so a typical zoo always has a barrier
and i think when bodhiban we
conceptualize a space where the child
or the children are in the same space as
animals so you would have
the opportunity to be right next to a
rabbit or have a hedgehog in your hand
and i think that is the kind of emotion
that cannot be replicated
and so we started to try to understand
you know
amongst those families with kids what
were some of the
unmet needs that families and the
parents have
one was the need for more frequent
animal interactions but coming to the
zoo was just too troublesome
[Music]
by understanding all these key tensions
that parents have
we have actually conceptualized my
animal body
now their children can actually look at
our live camps
participate in virtual shows there are
so many
a variety of virtual activities that
they can enjoy
which makes our animal interaction a lot
more frequent
than it used to be this is my big
brother
pasha i like to annoy him when i'm bored
that's what siblings are for right all
right let me show you my really cool
friend
lastly is the accessibility to my number
buddy
that even a child in alaska right can
get to know
kansa our orangutan
for these we are really transforming how
families with children
experience the zoo what i've always
termed exporting mandai out of mundane
in order to reach you know consumers
outside of the confines
of our wildlife parks there is no
perfect situation
there is no perfect role there is no
perfect circumstance for us to drive
change and to drive innovation and we
make the best out of what we are given
[Music]
picture yourself now in the zoo and what
do you see
i hope like me you see endless
[Music]
possibilities
[Music]
you